because we have i mean we have a lot of
things planned for this year um that are
you know out of outside of japan um not
spawning anything more than just that
but uh i'm hoping that we i get to uh
interact with people again you know yeah
that's that's that's the biggest thing
because convention i missed the vibe of
conventions you know i didn't realize
how much i missed it until
until you couldn't go to it anymore
right i just i just missed that whole
convention vibe and just the the
positive you know the positive air and
the positive attitude and just you know
having fun for a weekend yeah i just
love that like you know like that the
ambience of a a convention hall of just
like the low murder everywhere and it's
like exciting like everyone's just there
and excited and it's like you can feel
the hell i love
i didn't think i would miss the smell of
stale sweats that you yeah that you like
that you like smell in like the
concealer yourself i don't miss this
[ __ ]
god i mean i i don't i miss it i don't
miss it i just miss that that reminds me
that i am at a convention and this is
this is the smell of a convention when
you walk into like a clean room and
you're like damn it man
it ain't that ax smell though
there's no precipitation in the air
there's not enough gamer precipitation
in the air
i should miss it so much
so especially when you get those like
you know it'll be like a few months or
even like a year later and you know
someone will say like they'll be like oh
i met connor x and x you were so nice
and i'm like
oh that makes my day made even though
that might become a meme now someone
will be like i met connor at his twitch
chat he was so nice he called me an
idiot
i don't know i like being a dick online
with any person i'm like oh man i just
want to be nice to everyone i want i
want the opposite of that to be like oh
i met joey eddie connie was so nice i
haven't subscribed
i i i think i've had that one time
actually someone's like oh connor was so
rude or something and i i'm like i don't
think i was i'm i really would be rude
i could scarcely be rude to myself let
alone like someone else i'm only rude to
my best mates yeah yeah that's basically
yeah yeah i mean sometimes you have to
you know if you're if you're being
ushered to somewhere
of course you have to be like sometimes
people will shout like oh i can take a
picture and i'll be like well i can't
right now actually i have to i have to
go through it
you've
you've
changed
fell off l-plus ratio
before before like when you moved to
japan did you guys get called out by
your username or or by your real name
did anyone actually call you by like
always
or sebastian occasionally that remember
like yo sebastian remember that one time
we were in little tokyo right we were in
l.a
and we were chilling and then like we
were all about to like we're finally
we're done with our delicious uh i think
i think i didn't even have
uh japanese food i remember bibimbap
which is yeah yeah it was like the like
korean barbecue place right yeah so we
were leaving and it was good we were
chatting and some girls screamed like
sebastian
and i was like
and i was really just embarrassed
because you guys were [ __ ] laughing
at me because they called me sebastian
because because it was it was that
moment of like we all turned around and
we were like oh i wonder which the bat
oh
is just like
this is like in the period where i was
trying my goddamn hardest to get away
from this like a reminder i mean yeah i
don't care if someone did it you can
call me sebastian
i don't give a [ __ ] i think for me the
i think it happened early on where like
of course people at first were calling
me anime man or whatever but like yeah i
think i from really early on because too
many people were getting my usernames
wrong yeah and also the fact that i
didn't like my username what were they
calling you then if it was wrong oh
there was anime guy anime dude
it's not that hard that's no joke like
every time i hang out like i was next to
joey i swear he would get like anime man
maybe only like 70 percent of the time
if that there's been so many variations
but there but there were people who
would like get my actual name wrong as
well like i've been called john i've
been called the one that the one that i
couldn't [ __ ] believe and i
remembered to this day was adorable
takuthon some dude legit came up to me
and said hey josh
with like 100 confidence 100 confidence
and i was like respect to that guy i was
like
i couldn't even like be you know i
couldn't be like it's it's joey because
i was actually just dumbfounded i'm like
you did not just [ __ ] call me that do
you not like josh do you have a vendetta
against george oh nothing against josh
i've got mates called josh but i'm not
josh
why did the name josh specifically annoy
you more than john
i think it's because there's only ever
been that one guy who called me josh
watch it now next next day x or whatever
you're gonna be josh the anime guy i
understand you know like anime guy or
like anime dude or you know like
a different derivative of the word man
right because it's a pretty you know
it's a pretty generic name right the
anime man is pretty [ __ ] easy well
i'd like to think sorry actually like i
think i've gotten my like people have
gotten my name like my my my internet
handle yeah like wrong almost as much
times if they've got as they've got it
right yeah probably yeah uh because i
mean i think the biggest thing is
obviously people think my name's gig uk
yeah yeah yeah they're like oh i love
you i love it i love uh i love your work
gig uk and i'm just like how long have
you been watching my stuff
i think i think youtube should implement
those uh pronunciation brackets that you
have on those like miriam dictionary
they need like the google translate like
say the word is is my name that hard to
pronounce because i swear i've had so
many mispronounced
mish pronunciations of my name and it
doesn't even piss me off i just find it
funny right yeah
i don't ever say anything i'm just like
whatever we'll just well at least yours
is just a mispronunciation mine is
literally just not the correct word
like there's only so many ways you can
like i didn't know you could pronounce
man as dude
or guy i i think it's just because i've
just like my entire life is a
mispronunciation of my name like
that's i'm just i'm just [ __ ] used to
it i i think the weirdest mispronounced
mispronunciation of my real name
actually yeah uh was actually when i was
in university
so i remember in university in freshers
week especially you meet a lot of new
people very very quickly okay yeah and
obviously uh as you all know gantt is
not a common name at all right and you
know so i've heard like every [ __ ]
mispronounciations of my name by then
and i remember like my first day of uni
i heard a new one right
so i go up to i go to a person and i say
hi my name is gant thinking they say
grant or you know garnet or one of like
something like that which that happens a
lot garnet has happened
yeah yeah and and he goes and he goes
god
name's god i'm like what
how did you how did you miss and hear
that how did you miss hear that no it's
it's it's
not [ __ ] i always
it's gone it's gone because how i
explained it it's gone think of hugh
grant but swap the rna over yeah that's
gone and you know that's that's how i
like speed run
explaining my name yeah and he was just
like oh
god and i thinking i'm thinking in my
head what a [ __ ] dumb ass how would
you hear god from guards right that's
that's just like the anomaly he is the
glitch in the matrix and then literally
like
two people later right i'm like
introduce myself and so like later in
the day i say hi my name's garn and the
second time god your name's god i'm like
what what the [ __ ] is what is going on
what is going on right now a very bold
move of a parent to name their kid god
so very bold name
you gotta have high high hopes for that
kid
and i remember somehow in freshers week
even though i did introduce myself to a
lot of people within that short time
frame like probably more than i have in
my life in that like one week or two
period three people thought my name was
god when i first introduced myself i i i
just i like it blew my [ __ ] mind i i
just i just love it when like people
just absolutely butcher my name in ways
that i just like wasn't expecting i
think that is like my favorite thing
ever just like having
now that i am like this public figure
where like you know even like my full
name is like public now right like yeah
oh my god i don't think there's no
there's been a there hasn't been a
single person who's pronounced my
surname correct really it's the first
time
yeah it's bizinjo right but like my
favorite was the [ __ ] fccj uh panel
that we did
and the guy i think the guy called me
something like and here at the end of
the table is joey the anime bazinga
first of all you forgot the man
second of all uh
i didn't interview we should be you
should be the anime yeah the anime yeah
right anime
joey the anime man
drop the guy the anime the anime i am
anime you are the
anime not the man the anime
i think what i loved about that uh that
live stream with fccj is when he was
introducing my name and like i remember
he like introduced you he introduced
connor and then he i think he got to me
i remember and this is and i could see
like i could see the [ __ ] word
processing in his mind and there was
like this brief pause before he said my
name and it was like it was like i i
remember like the chat going he's gonna
say grant
he's
he's going to mispronounce it and i
remember it was just like a slight pause
but that felt like a [ __ ] that felt
like an hour you know
that felt like an entire death note
scene that [ __ ] pause man
you could have edited in like the aol
loadings
one second
three seconds
has anyone ever mispronounced sea dog or
gotten your internet and all wrong no
your surname is pretty difficult to
pronounce yeah name but
also c dog is very easy as well yes i'm
really glad i chose that i mean we've
said this before right smart and easy
unintentionally i i you know
chose it to sound cool yeah it doesn't
actually sound that cool
but now everyone calls me connor so
that's easy yeah well that's what i like
about trash taste is that now we're just
known as joey garden corner yeah i i
have a request to anyone watching this
who will meet us in conventions uh i
know grant is a meme and it doesn't piss
me off when people uh call me grant um
but please call me gans because
it will get to a point where i literally
will not know if you just don't know who
i am or you're part of a you're a trash
taste viewer so please at least call me
ghand the first time before you start
memeing it up uh otherwise i would
genuinely not know like if if if you
just are that deep into the trash taste
law or if you just genuinely think my
name's grant like i genuinely genuinely
won't be able to tell likewise with me
um you know josh is not my name
john is always it is i've seen this
person it is if you call him josh now
everyone's gonna know that you watch
this episode of trash taste
how come i'm not allowed to get away
with it what the [ __ ] yeah go inside
don't do this to me but do it in joey
yeah don't do it to me
don't do the exercise as long as it's
not to me
bully joey
joey just don't bully me i'm begging you
i can't believe it
sorry people just spell my name
incorrectly that's all people say it
wrong well i mean there's only so many
ways you can [ __ ] pronounce connor
yeah oh it's all yeah yeah conor maybe
that's conair
conair conair i
that sounds like the cursive connor you
know it's like if sebastian pronounces
connor
maybe maybe
that's what that's what you should be
like if someone at a convention stops
you being like hey sebastian you should
be like it's corn air i never saw in my
life until like i got on the internet
that you could spell connor with an er
connor
connor
c-o-n-n yeah i mean i never saw that as
a friend of my school it was called
connor but we spelt c-o-n-n-a-h
corner
uh
near me that was called connor something
right um
but we spot that one that is like a very
phonetic con isn't it
corner yeah
it was interesting cause i was like am i
the weird no i've got the normal i have
them yeah yours is the normal one
i'm pretty sure i'm the real one this is
all a joke you're all you're all lying
none of you are the real connor what
what is the uh
like who was the person who had the
weirdest name that you that you knew
personally
in your life what are you judges weird
like obscure or just okay so how would
you choose for me i knew a guy in my
school whose first name whose real name
was gameron
gammaron yeah not cameron
gameron with a g i kind of like that i
thought it was [ __ ] cool that sounds
cool but it's just like i in my head i
was like
first of all where does that come from
and second of all was like their parents
handwriting so [ __ ] at the birth
certificate that the doctor was like oh
that's an interesting that's an
interesting way to spell cameron i there
was a kid from another school i i always
was so jealous he they'd call to that
kid zeus
zeus was his first name [ __ ] yeah dude
and i was like i was like again the
problem with really [ __ ] badass names
is that if you don't live up to a badass
name it is looks pathetic like imagine
like you're like a kind of like super
shy person you're like yeah what's your
name oh it's zeus
it's like
you need to be larger than life if
you're called zeus right that's like
that's like in school when you had that
like one surname like you know i i knew
a guy who's whose surname was champion
oh
and uh
unfortunately was it was he a champion
unfortunately no
wow he didn't quite live up to his
service it was a surname though because
if it was your first time everyone's
calling you
the parents must have been confident
they'd be like yeah you better live up
to this name or you're a failure you are
a literal champion
like the sperm bank got the highest
grade
sperm they're like nine foot guy
went to harvard 10 000 iq they're like
this guy's a zeus from 100
was it actually spelled like the gold
exact same like god uh that's so badass
and i remember because we i i i threw
javelin against him um
i was like this is amazing i even i i
was like this is great i beat zeus i did
the time i didn't care though but now
now i'm like i'd be juicy javelin
it's not a big deal it is but it is yeah
one of my mates who used to live here in
japan uh australian guy uh his his real
full name was storm angus
that was like the most australian
actress i've ever heard that is the most
badass when he introduced himself as
that i was like no you're not that's
that's just an australian superhero name
right
look it's still vegas
oh yeah [ __ ] game
sounds like a superhero
[Laughter]
oh my god